in the state of tennessee i'm a licensed
marital and family therapist which
basically means i've been trained up to
think about like systems family systems
how we were raised up how that shapes
who we are today so on your website if
you'll if you'll bear with me sure
quoting you say i use a combination of
approaches in my therapeutic work
including anti-oppression feminist and
narrative frameworks i rely deeply on
systems theory and understanding that
individuals are products of and in
dialogue with our surroundings including
our families broader culture workplaces
nature and political climates
what
does that mean
yeah um so
thinking about the modalities that i use
um i'm definitely informed by like
feminist
family therapy
and the idea is that
we live in gendered worlds where there
are certain imperatives that are placed
on us about who we are and what we do
based on how we've been gendered from
the minute i was assigned female i was
told okay these are the kind of clothing
that you're going to wear these are the
kind of the type of play that you're
going to engage in as a child um the
path that maybe your life will take
because of social expectations what do
you mean by a signed female who
who
assigns
females yeah so um most times people
when they're born um they're assigned to
gender by the
doctor doctors yeah
what do they what do they base that
assignment on
so basically it's it's based on
genitalia um
so people looking at genitalia and
deciding okay this is a girl or a boy
and we know now that like that sex and
gender are so much more than just this
binary some women have penises right
some men have vaginas
um that that that's not how how gender
works how do we know that how do we know
that that's not true where do we where
did we learn that from yeah well we i i
learned that um from
hearing from transgender people who've
said like oh i'm a trans woman
and just because i happen to have a
penis right that doesn't mean that this
is like who i am as a person um or or
that genitalia doesn't equal gender
who they are their gender their gender
expression um
that yeah a trans woman is a woman
with the fluidity of these things
how do i know if if i'm a woman you know
i i
that's a great question i like scented
candles yeah i've watched sex in the
city yeah
um yeah
so how do i know yeah matt that question
right there like that question
is
like when it's asked with a lot of
curiosity right that's the beginning of
a lot of people's like gender identity
development journeys if my mom who gave
birth to me is
a woman
and my wife is a woman
though i haven't asked her
maybe i should um
but if they're all women and also the
boy who sits down with you and says i
think i'm a girl
actually is one then then what is a
woman um
question i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that